[Applause]
wonderful to be with you and you have my
man here ross matthews rozzy
i love him so much
i sent him a text i said oh my god you
look so good you look so happy he said
stop flirting with me i'm engaged
and now he and i pretend like there's a
possibility there and we know clearly
there's not and that's weirdly why it's
going to work yeah for the long term
exactly um and you get so into really
great deep stuff in your book
love me as i am which how is that title
say a brilliant title oh thank you i
mean i wanted something that said this
is who i am do you know what i mean like
take me as i am basically and love me as
i am felt a little nicer i mean you talk
about your family your father your
mother
will you talk to me about their
relationship because i was freaking out
about the dynamic that they had yeah
what was interesting is my dad left when
i was three so i really only knew my mom
and only knew her story as much as she
told me and there wasn't much told
because
back then in haiti kids were seen and
not heard right
and so i saw her be this strong
independent woman and that's what i knew
and it was interesting when my dad came
back into our lives i was 14
and i saw that she kind of gave up her
power because he became the man of the
house
and and culturally that's also a thing
you know in the islands the men sort of
ruled the roost so it was interesting to
see her her change
in that way she was still strong but in
a different way and and your f your
grandfather and his wife is there a
pattern here in new york sure there's a
pattern and i talked about that pattern
also um my grandfather you know was
obviously a very strong
um he had a strong presence i remember
when i would go and visit them like just
who he was was bigger than life for me
right
and uh and then he left my grandmother
and got a younger woman and created a
whole new family
with you know with her and it was just
interesting that there were patterns
and my dad you know also left my mom and
then you know i chose men that were
similar to my dad in in some instinct
and i think we do that and i know one of
my patterns is like my dad left when i
was three
my i got divorced when my son oliver was
three and then i got divorced when my
two boys were three
and i have three boys and i'm like what
is that
what is that i feel like there's
something to that i don't know what it
is
now that you're looking at this pattern
you're seeing your life your family is
writing this gorgeous book love me as i
am
where are you at now
waiting for my soul mate honestly i
think where i am now is i feel like i'm
really i feel like 50s is fearless right
i feel like i'm in my skin i know who i
am i know what i want and it's just
waiting for the right time to meet the
right person i'm don't like apps
i know some people do
and that's fine i just for me i find it
a little tough to be swiping i'd rather
be doing that like with clothes yeah on
a rack
it i agree um now i want to talk about
the real housewives garth
i'm dying everyone is freaking out
what is going on everyone's a buzz on
the internet freaking out about um the
book
in the in the
erica put it in the trash what this is
classic housewives everybody's in for it
that's the way they're dialed out oh my
god sorry it is it's a juggernaut of a
show i can't believe how many people are
invested into everything we do i mean it
is a cult i mean it's crazy with 8 000
spin-offs this is like it's taken all
over the world
um you know what i posted a clip that
was in the trailer of our new season
and uh i guess erica felt a certain way
about it clearly uh clearly and uh i
wish her well
the look says it all
that's high road with a i see you
you should be a housewife come come on
true
ironically i used to love drama and now
i am as far away from it as possible but
when we come back we have some people
right here in our studio audience who
actually are looking for a few dating
pointers tips garcelle oh we got them
okay we got it
[Music]